[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMMA FALLONE: I am so
pleased to introduce the very
special panel that
we have with us today
to discuss the results
of the incredibly
successful recent auction
hosted by Christie's, as well
as the continuing philanthropic
legacy of the Rockefeller
family.
So to start, let me
introduce our guests who
will be speaking with us today.
So first, at the end, we
have David Rockefeller Jr
is a longstanding businessman
and philanthropist.
He has held many
significant positions
among Rockefeller-related
entities,
as well as the nonprofits that
support the arts, education,
and the environment.
He is currently a trustee
of the Rockefeller Brothers
Fund and the David
Rockefeller Fund
and a member of Council
on Foreign Relations.
A passionate supporter of
the arts, Mr. Rockefeller
has been a trustee of
the Museum of Modern Art
for nearly four decades, as
well as on the Asian-American
Cultural Council.
He served as citizen chair of
the National Parks Foundation
from 1995 to 2005.
And in 2013, Mr. Rockefeller
and two of his sisters
established the Peggy McGrath
Rockefeller Foundation,
Stone House Grain, which
manages 2,000 acres of farmland
in Columbia County,
New York, and promotes
regenerative agriculture and
supporting young farmers.
Finally, Mr.
Rockefeller's commitment
to environmental preservation
and his passion for sailing
led him to found the nonprofit
Sailors for the Sea in 2004,
now joined with the global
ocean conservation organization,
Oceana.
JONATHAN RENDELL: That's good.
EMMA FALLONE: As
director, Mr. Rockefeller
promotes the organization's
campaign driven work to sailors
worldwide.
Next, Susan Rockefeller is
an award-winning documentary
filmmaker, artist,
and conservationist.
Her latest endeavor, "Musings,"
is a digital magazine
that creates ideas
and innovations that
pave the way for a more
sustainable future.
Susan interviews thought
leaders and entrepreneurship,
responsible innovation,
and social impact
to provide inspirational
calls for action and solutions
for positive change.
A longstanding
philanthropist, Susan
sits on the boards of
Oceana, Stone Barns Center
for Food and Agriculture, We
Are the Family Foundation,
Southampton Arts Center, and
Land and Garden Preserve.
In her film work, Susan is a
principal of Louverture Films
and a member of
the film committee
of the Museum of Modern Art.
Her own original films
have aired on HBO, PBS,
and the Discovery Channel.
They include "Food for
Thought," "Food for Life,"
"Striking a Chord," "Making
the Crooked Straight,"
"Bach Star Café," and
"Mission of the Mermaids."
And then finally, we
have Jonathan Rendell,
the deputy chairman of
Christie's Americas.
Mr. Rendell drives senior
business development
and is a top level client
liaison in many areas
of Christie's business.
He was on the core team
overseeing the collection
of Yves Saint Laurent and
Pierre Bergé at Christie's Paris
in 2009, which achieved a
record-breaking $483.8 million
in sales.
Other notable
collections with which
Mr. Rendell was instrumental
include the collection
of Elizabeth Taylor at
Christie's New York in 2011,
and the sale of the
collection of Roger Hatfield
Ellsworth in 2014, which
made $134 million, also
record-breaking.
Prior to joining
Christie's, Mr. Rendell
served as the head of the
print department of Phillips,
the London-based auctioneer.
He has published
and lectured widely.
Most recently, Mr.
Rendell is a key member
of the senior
management team that
oversaw the sale of the
Peggy and David Rockefeller
collection, which achieved a
record-breaking $832 million,
the highest total ever for
any single-owner collection
at auction and the most
significant charitable auction
in history, as well as the
reason that we are here today.
So Jonathan-- well, first,
let's welcome our presenters.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Thank you.
EMMA FALLONE: Thank you.
And Jonathan, to
get us started, I
know this must have been a
pretty incredible auction
week with one historic
sale after another.
Can you talk a bit about
the action, its goals,
and its results?
JONATHAN RENDELL:
Yeah, absolutely.
Less an auction week,
more an auction year.
We had an
extraordinary privilege
in working with Mr.
Rockefeller's family
to put this sale together
over a period of time,
which made a huge difference
to the way we approached it.
I think for
Christie's internally,
this was incredibly important as
the sale that really pushed us
forward on the
digital platforms,
on many other different ways
of marketing the things.
But what was also incredibly
interesting and important
for us was the philanthropic
aspect of this.
This is the biggest charity
sale that's ever been held.
And I think we all felt
a huge responsibility
whilst going through the motions
of putting a sale together.
We've all done great big sales.
But this was completely
different in that it
wasn't to profit an individual.
This was to profit a whole
series of philanthropies, which
I think is an incredibly
important way forward
for a lot of our collectors.
We've already started talking
to quite a lot of other people
about how they can adapt the
Rockefeller pattern to what
they want to do with their
collections going forward.
EMMA FALLONE: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
The clicker doesn't
seem to be working.
If you could advance the slides.
JONATHAN RENDELL: I think
what might be interesting
for everybody is just
to see a short video
that we've been working
on that sums up the sale.
And then let's get into the
more interesting bit, which
is us grilling them.
EMMA FALLONE: Absolutely.
Sounds good.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [INAUDIBLE] that
is $71,500,000.
[BANGS GAVEL]
Yours it is.
For the "Nympheas en fleur," $75
million, ladies and gentlemen.
Sid, you have it.
Sold to you.
The great Picasso, at $100
million, $102 million.
Larry, do you have it?
- Ladies and gentleman, this is
the "Marley Rouge," $1,500,000.
[BANGS GAVEL] Well done.
The Diego Rivera, "The Rivals,"
selling for $8,400,000.
[BANGS GAVEL]
The O'Keeffe, the "Near
Abiquiú," $7,200,000.
[BANGS GAVEL]
For you, sir.
The Gilbert Stuart portrait of
George Washington, $7,700,000
and selling at Christie's
for $10 million.
Sold to you.
- The beautiful "Whistling
Swan," $280,000.
[BANGS GAVEL]
Sold.
- And we go to Delacroix.
[AIRPLANE ENGINE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[GAVEL BANGS]
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
JONATHAN RENDELL: Here comes
the first really important
question.
What would they have thought?
What would Peggy and
David have thought
of this great
hoopla that ended up
with this extraordinary result?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Well,
I've wondered that myself.
My mother, who died
more than 20 years ago,
and my dad, who just died last
year, they shared many things.
They were both very competitive.
So they would have
loved the fact
that this was the best
in many categories.
They would have loved that.
It also would have
been, I think,
Jonathan, a testament
to their taste,
which I always
thought was very good.
It wasn't always my taste.
But it was wonderful taste in
the things that they bought.
So they would have loved that.
And then they would
have been so pleased
that the institutions, 12 of
them at least, that they cared
about received so much
money, in some cases,
twice as much as
they really expected.
So anyway, that was
absolutely wonderful.
And I think it's on
to the next question.
JONATHAN RENDELL: It is indeed.
EMMA FALLONE: And
you were talking
about those foundations
that will be receiving
the benefits of this auction.
And I know that perhaps the
greatest Rockefeller legacy
is the family's commitment
to philanthropy, which runs
throughout the generations.
So can you talk more a bit about
your family's unique approach
to giving over time?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: Well, both Sue
and I come from
philanthropic families.
But let me start, if I could, in
terms of my parents' philosophy
and the impact of this sale.
I think what's
maybe most important
is their recognition
that endowment
is a critical element
in the nonprofit sector,
having funds that are
actually releasing income
every year because earned
income and contributed
income is very hard to come by.
So they were so
focused on endowments.
And a very good example
of the power of that
is the Stone Barns Center
for Food and Agriculture
in Westchester County.
Susan actually
sits on the board.
And you can talk a little bit
about the content of that.
But endowment was
very key to them.
Yeah.
Would you like to
say a bit more.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
Sure, I could say.
I mean, what's great
about endowment
is that the
institutions can get on
with either the research
or the experimentation
and not worry about
extensive fundraising.
So with the case of
Stone Barns, we now
have unbelievable opportunity to
continue the work in resilient
agriculture and research in
what we're calling slow tools.
Because there is this resurgence
of small-scale farming,
and there's not a lot
of tools and technology
that actually is working
for the small-scale farmers.
So it's this big sigh of relief.
We can go into the board
meeting and actually
think about how we can
create more immersive
experiences, more educational
outreach from K to 12,
to educating
next-generation farmers.
So it's just
unbelievable that there
is that sense of freedom
that comes from building
an endowment like that.
EMMA FALLONE: Absolutely.
And I feel like
this speaks a lot
to the idea of patient
capital, which is, I know,
something that your family
believes in as well,
the idea of open-ended giving.
If you could speak
a bit to that.
I know Stone Barns
is one example.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Yeah.
I mean, I think
patient capital relates
to not expecting instant
results, as often in business,
and particularly in
research-oriented businesses,
it takes a long time for
something to germinate.
And that's the same in much
of the nonprofit world.
So not only having the capital,
but being patient with it,
I think it's
extremely important.
My parents also really
believed in the importance
of leadership, or really
three things together--
passion for whatever it was.
That's the kernel.
That's the key first step--
and then leadership, your
own leadership, hopefully,
to guide the
institution, and money.
But the three together,
philanthropy not just
being about the money.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: And then
in terms of patient capital,
just an example that there is a
saying that you aren't thinking
big enough if you can solve
the problem that you're
looking at in your lifetime.
So whether it's some
of the philanthropy
that my family has done
with the Wilderness Society
and working to preserve
millions of acres of wilderness
in the United
States-- we're working
on peace in the Middle East
with an institute at Tel Aviv
University on the history
and philosophy of science
and ideas.
Patient capital is really
that long-term view.
And it's not something
that happens quickly.
It's not a quick fix.
And a great example is the
Peking Union Medical College,
that it was one of the
oldest philanthropic--
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: You're
seeing it on the screen here.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
--gifts that you can see.
And the work is still
sowing incredible rewards
in our travels to Asia now.
EMMA FALLONE: Something
that has truly passed down
throughout the generations.
JONATHAN RENDELL: And I don't
want to sound impatient.
But what you see as
the immediate result
as opposed to the
long-term capital thing
is fantastic and
incredibly important.
What will be the immediate
result of the sale?
I'm constantly thinking about
what happens after the sale.
How do we move onto
the next phase?
So is there an immediate result?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: You know, I
mean there were 12
different institutions.
And so you can imagine that when
a significant number of dollars
comes to a Harvard
University, they already
have a significant
number of dollars.
My father was interested
in two particular things.
And so they'll get guided
in those directions.
One was urging all students
during their college years
to become familiar with
a culture not their own,
hopefully a nation not
their own, and so to travel.
And he provided funds for that.
And then the other, related
but slightly different,
was support of what's called
the DR Center for Latin American
Studies, his great interest in
the continent south of North
America and the Latin cultures.
And so the result
will be that Harvard
will be pushed to be more
global and more hemispherically
inclusive.
JONATHAN RENDELL: And Sue,
with your real interest
in the environment and the
future of the environment,
how will it impact the immediate
needs of the world, which
is constantly challenged.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
Well, I would say
that one of the most exciting
collaborative partnerships
that we're involved with is
the Peggy McGrath Rockefeller
Foundation and the 2,000 acres
of regenerative agriculture
in the Hudson Valley.
So with that influx
of more funds,
there'll be more opportunities
to really innovate.
We're working with the Woods
Hole Oceanographic Institute,
looking at how the
carbon sequestration is
happening with the
application of cover
cropping on our fields.
So there's a research component.
And when you're experimenting
and innovating for a change,
it costs money, and to
not have to seek funding,
but actually have
it there so that we
can start sharing our findings
and actually find other people.
There's a lot of interesting
work going on in California
in regenerative agriculture.
And we have the ability to
actually do this research
and not be constrained by the
constant fundraising cycle.
So to me, that's super exciting.
And then I sit on the board
of the Land & Garden Preserve
in Maine.
And we have three gardens.
And it really is looking at the
intersection of man-made design
and the beauty of horticulture
with the natural beauty
of Acadia National Park.
So that too will be
endowed so that we
can bring more visitors.
There's something like
three million visitors
that come to Acadia
National Park,
and to be able to leverage that
with the educational component
of what does it mean
to garden and create
beauty in a natural landscape.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
And to charge less.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: T0 the public.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
Yeah, exactly.
JONATHAN RENDELL: One of
the most significant things,
I think, that we
at Christie's came
to learn during
this whole process
was the intertwining of
Rockefeller philanthropy
and social history in
America and elsewhere.
I mean, obviously,
we talked briefly
about the Peking Medical College
and the importance of that.
But if you could talk just
briefly about historically,
the family's involvement,
not just your parents,
which your parents' is enormous.
But there is a whole
thing behind them,
which I think is very important
for people to understand,
this very long-term view of
how you make things better.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: Exactly right.
So it is often said that the
Carnegies and the Rockefeller
families were the
ones who, in a sense,
invented modern philanthropy.
What does that mean,
modern philanthropy?
Well, I think what it
meant was sometimes what's
called scientific philanthropy.
And charity was being
moved to give funds
to the immediately needy,
whom you could, perhaps,
see on the street, a
wonderful human gesture.
Scientific
philanthropy is to try
to figure out why there are
so many people on the streets
in the first place and
create a more systemic answer
to that problem.
When we were seeing the slide
of the Peking Union Medical
College in Beijing, which was
founded about 105 years ago
by the Rockefeller
Foundation, one
of the first scientific
philanthropies,
you were seeing not just a
response to sick Chinese people
on the street,
although that may have
been an emotional
cause for the founding,
but you were also seeing
a response to the fact
that, at that time,
medical practices in China
were very rudimentary.
And so this was the first
modern hospital in China.
And I'm so proud that
it still exists today.
Susan and I have visited
it several times.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
A number of times.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: So it's
a kind of a thoughtfulness
that obviously
companies like Google
need to be thoughtful about
what will business success mean
next decade.
You can't sit on your laurels.
And philanthropy
is really the same.
JONATHAN RENDELL: And
over the past year--
I'm not looking for praise.
But over the past year--
although if you want to
offer some, I wouldn't mind.
No, over the last year, while
we've gone on this journey
together, we've
changed as a company.
Christie's has
It's changed the way that
we think about what we do.
How has it changed things
for the two of you?
What have you learnt?
How do you feel about this
extraordinary gesture?
I mean, the amount of money
involved is staggering.
For that all to go at
once to the philanthropies
your parents cared
for is mind-boggling.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: It is.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
Do you want to start?
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Yeah,
well, what I hope--
and it's something
that you mentioned
earlier-- is that other people
with significant collections
will start to think about
where they can take an auction,
where those proceeds
can go and also benefit
institutions that could
use more financial support.
So if this becomes
a trend that there's
more people that will give--
And there's been a history.
There was a Yves Klein that
went to Oceana, the proceeds
that Loic, who was
there, facilitated.
It was a million
dollar painting.
And Oceana got the
benefit to that.
So finding people that have--
when you can marry your passion
with art and philanthropy,
and then choosing
a few paintings--
it doesn't have to be
your whole collection.
It's extraordinary
that the Rockefellers
had their whole collection
go to philanthropy.
But at least to me, that's one
of the most exciting trends,
if it does happen, that
there'll be more people thinking
in terms of, I have this
painting I bought for $10,000.
It's now $150,000.
Give it to an institution
or your alma mater,
and think about broader
ways of making impact.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: It's like
giving a low base of stock when
the value increases
and you get the benefit
of the deduction for the
current value, not just
the lower value.
I have a very different
answer, Jonathan.
And it has to do with you.
And that is to say that
when you've grown up
living with something in
an environment in which,
as in my case, the
houses my parents
had were full of all
sorts of objects--
they were very big on
tchotchkes, especially
porcelain tchotchkes.
And--
JONATHAN RENDELL: Also known
as incredibly valuable pieces
of art.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Which is
what I learned from Jonathan,
that it wasn't just
odd little tchotchkes,
but that they had a value
that was both monetary,
but maybe, much more
importantly, aesthetic.
And so by actually-- when
Christie's set them aside
in cases, or hung them
on a wall by themselves,
I really saw these pieces
in a very different way.
And so that was a
great gift, Jonathan.
Thank you for leading
the way on that.
And I think it says something
about context and the way
that we see.
You know?
I look out here.
It's hard to see people.
But it's an agglomeration
of faces I can't quite see.
But each one of your
faces is very distinct.
Each one of your personalities
is very distinct.
That was true about
the collection too.
So I really learned about that.
Thank you very much.
JONATHAN RENDELL: Yeah, I
mean, always with a collection,
it's a biography in objects.
I get to know people
incredibly well,
usually after they're
no longer with us,
because I know what they liked.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
Isn't that interesting?
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
And I would just
say that we spent years looking
at all this art that was--
there was beautiful curtains.
And you couldn't
really separate it.
It was just all part of the
decoration of the house.
And I thought that Christie's
did such an outstanding job
on lighting everything and
being able to really take
that moment.
And the other thought is that
Christie's is about-- we're
both conservationists.
And it is the best reuse of
the most beautiful objects
that your family enjoyed.
And now it's gone on to
either private collections,
or private collectors,
or museums.
And the value of that
beauty is timeless.
JONATHAN RENDELL: And
another extraordinary aspect,
of course, is not just
you, the two of you,
who we've been talking to
a lot during this process.
It's your siblings.
It's the next generation
of the Rockefellers.
There is this DNA that
you have of philanthropy,
which sets you somewhat
apart from other people.
But I know that you are both
very strongly personally
involved in
philanthropies that aren't
necessarily the ones that
were the ones favored
by your parents.
And I wonder if you could talk
for a little while about what
your interests are and
how you differ from them
in your interests.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: That's good.
I have a very close relationship
to a Unitarian Church called
All Souls on the
Upper East Side.
And I love it because of their
commitment to beautiful words,
including poetry and great
sermons, and beautiful music.
We have an amazing choir, and
a resident chamber quartet,
and a fantastic
community program,
two nights a week feeding
250 individuals, who
live not far away, but
don't have regular meals.
And that's such a
wonderful thing.
And it really binds us to that
community and that church.
It's very personal.
We are donors.
We're active with the church.
And so that's a
very different thing
from being on the board of the
Museum of Modern Art, which
I've also been, as Emma
mentioned, for nearly 40 years.
That's such a large
institution, such a large board.
We've just enlarged
the board to 70 people,
whereas the church is really
about something much more
immediate.
And both are wonderful,
and very different.
And so you have this wonderful
community connection to We
Are Family, among other things.
That's so different.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Yeah.
So I mean, we do a lot
together as a couple.
But I also sit on
the board of We
Are Family
Foundation, which is--
I don't know if people
here know Nile Rodgers, who
wrote the song "We Are
Family and "Let's Dance."
He's a amazing
musician and composer.
And I made a film with him
way back, a long ways back,
called "Striking a Chord,"
on our troops, and PTSD,
and using music as a way to
help with the healing process.
And this is a very
small foundation.
There's about 12
of us on the board.
And it's about
training and mentoring
next generation leaders.
So if you know anybody in
their teenage, early 20s
that are looking
for great mentors,
we bring people together from
around the world for one week
of intensive training.
And you know, we would love
to see that next generation.
And they are really addressing
and taking on these challenges.
And every time I go
to this board meeting
and I meet these
young people, I am
so excited because
they are innovating
on the environment,
and with bullying,
with internet innovations.
And it's just-- it's remarkable.
So I think that's something
that your parents wouldn't
necessarily have
supported, but it is
global in its network of youth.
JONATHAN RENDELL: And joint
ventures which you do together?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Well,
I think the principal one now
is really about
ocean conservation.
A lot of ocean news these
days-- it didn't used to be
so, but whether it's
sea level rise--
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
Plastic pollution.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: Acidification,
plastic pollution.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
Decline in fish.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
A decline in fishing,
or fisheries and fish.
The oceans are under stress.
So it was mentioned
earlier about my Sailors
for the Sea effort,
a smaller entity that
lives in Newport, Rhode Island.
That's just been merged up
into the larger Oceana, where
Sue already was on the board.
Now both of us are on the board.
And it's a fantastic global
campaign organization
to protect the oceans.
But you should say more.
You've been on for a
longer time than I have.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Yeah, it's
the biggest NGO solely focused
on ocean protection.
And we invite all of you
to become Wavemakers.
Anyone can sign on--
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: No cost.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: No cost.
And you'll learn
all about what's
happening with the oceans.
And they're just
making a difference.
They're saving the oceans.
We have a campaign to save
the oceans and feed the world.
We're working on
plastic pollution.
We go country by country.
And it's really just--
what we find is 71%, as you
know, of our Earth is ocean.
And over a billion people rely
on fish for their major source
of protein.
So we want to keep
the oceans healthy
and keep the levels
of fish abundant so
that we don't have to
cut down more trees
and have more cattle.
The whole idea is that, from
a climate change standpoint,
we really want to keep
our oceans abundant.
So we love working
together on Oceana.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
Including fundraising.
And Christie's was several
times the host of a fundraiser
both for Sailors for the Sea--
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
Yeah, and Oceana.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Or Oceana.
And there'll be another
fundraiser in New York
this fall.
And Sue is the chair
of that effort.
So as a board
member, you give what
you can, either in time,
or talent, or treasure,
as they say.
And one of your responsibilities
is to help fundraise.
And Sue is a very good one.
So watch out.
[LAUGHTER]
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: I'll
send you all invites.
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA FALLONE: Fabulous.
So I know just talking
about the ocean efforts
that you're related to, given
that we are here at Google,
I'd love to talk a
little bit about the ways
that technology
in particular can
aid in philanthropic giving.
Can you talk to some
of the projects that
have a technological bent that
you've been involved with?
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Sure.
So one that actually
has Google at its source
is something called
Global Fishing Watch.
So here we go.
There's a slide.
So Global Fishing
Watch was basically
created with Oceana,
SkyTruth, and Google,
and primarily funded through the
Leonardo DiCaprio Foundation.
He was one of the lead
transformational funders
for this.
So we are very grateful to him.
And what it does is it
allows, in almost real time,
surveillance of
global fishing vessels
so that you can help with--
and anyone, NGOs,
governments, activists
can look and see if vessels
are in illegal waters,
so that it will help
with transparency,
with IUU, illegal, unreported,
and unregulated fishing.
So it is just a game changer.
And our goal is to really
bring it to global scale.
So I think technology plays a
huge role in the surveillance
aspect, especially if
you don't have funding
for enforcement on the ocean.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: You can't
really have a police force--
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
You can't police them.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
--on the entire ocean,
which covers more
than 70% of the globe.
And so this is a way,
instead of having
a vast set of police
boats out there
that you have this surveillance.
So if a ship--
and mainly, we're focused
on large fishing boats--
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Large
industrial fishing vessels.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: --is
either in an area it shouldn't
be, as in a marine protected
area, or taking stocks
that it's not licensed to take,
the surveillance catches them.
And they can be punished,
which until recently,
they really couldn't be.
So thanks to Google.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
Thank you, Google.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
Yes, yeah, exactly.
EMMA FALLONE: And do you see--
I know the additional
funds will obviously
help support this technology.
But can you also see
kind of more of the funds
that have been raised even
expanding this technology,
or allowing technology
to play a larger
role in some of your other
philanthropic efforts?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
It's a good question.
And as many of you know, some
of that same GPS technology
is being applied to agriculture.
And so when fertilizing
machines, or seeding machines,
are going over a
piece of terrain,
there's information
about the chemistry
of the soil that they're passing
over, the fertility of it.
And so in real time,
with this technology,
a single driver could
be passing over.
And the field has
been mapped as to what
needs more of one chemical,
what part of the field
needs more of one
chemical than another.
And so you don't just apply
the same coating of everything
everywhere.
But it's really customized.
I mean, that never--
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: That's huge.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
--happened before.
And so it's a wonderful
way in which technology is
helping the production of food.
In fact, you might say that both
of these technological examples
are ultimately about
healthy food for us humans.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: And it's
called precision agriculture.
So you can pinpoint
what parts of the field
need either more water,
more nitrogen, more--
if you're doing regenerative,
it would be manure [INAUDIBLE],,
or inputs.
But you're not adding
so much input that--
so it's game changing as well.
So--
EMMA FALLONE: Absolutely.
And it's so exciting to think
of how much more we can enable
as technology gets better,
and as the philanthropic work
continues.
So I know we've talked a
lot about the momentous
scale of the action.
I think that's one of the things
that has obviously generated
so much buzz and attention.
But I think there's also a lot
that I would hope to learn,
that I would hope
others would learn,
on a much more individual,
kind of even everyday basis.
And you both are so
experienced in philanthropy
on various scales.
So could you give maybe any
practical advice or tips
for people who are looking at
this, who are reading the news,
and wanting to get more
involved in philanthropy
in whatever ways they're able?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
Do you want to start?
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Sure.
Well, first of all, both
of us really believe--
and I'm sure all of you--
that passion is key.
So if you're working a day job
and it's not your passion--
hopefully it is-- but you
want to find something
that you are passionate
about because that's
going to keep you going.
And a lot of the issues and
the challenges that face us
are not easy to solve.
So you want to have
that tenaciousness,
and stick-to-itiveness to
really stay with an organization
and take that long-term view.
So once you identify
what the passion is,
it's just researching
the options.
There's a lot of groups involved
in ocean conservation, land
preservation,
education, whatever
it is, hunger, immigration
issues, voter rights.
I mean, there are so many.
And to just do your homework and
find out who the leadership is.
I really believe that
finding those leaders that
are really at the forefront of
being efficient, and effective,
and charismatic are the
ones, at least for me,
that I get attracted to.
But I would say the
passion, the research,
and then engage in whatever
way, whether it's your time,
volunteering, donating.
Obviously, many of
these organizations
need social media and some
of the skills that all of you
have here.
So it's just finding your way
and seeing what's the best.
But I really do think so much
of philanthropy comes from--
the root of it is love
of mankind or humankind.
And I think it's finding
what it is that you truly
want to engage with,
and connect with,
and following that path
because I really do believe--
I'll give you an example.
I was passionate
about Alaska and also
passionate about gardening.
In my early 20s, I
went up to Alaska.
I still love Alaska.
I was involved with
a foundation there.
20 years later, I
end up meeting David
because we both had
a passion for Alaska
and ended up making
a film together.
So I think if you
follow your passion,
it takes you on a path
that is quite remarkable.
And just to have faith
in that passion and just
see where it takes you.
EMMA FALLONE: David,
do you have anything
to add from that, from
maybe your experience
of the charities that
you've worked with?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: Yeah, no, I
think that's a wonderful
answer that Sue gave.
Yeah, no, I don't think that I--
I don't think that I do.
I think so many people
feel that philanthropy
is about big dollars.
And big dollars are great.
And if you have them, wonderful.
But it really is
also about impulse,
and research, and serious
purpose of giving.
So I think that
was a great answer.
Thank you, Sue.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: I could say
one thing about social impact
investing.
There are many interesting
hybrids happening now
with social impact investing.
And I can talk to one.
I'm an advisor to a nonprofit
called Food System 6, which
is based out of California.
And they have a
nonprofit arm where
they identify entrepreneurs
that are looking for food system
change.
So it could be anything
from cricket farming,
to pasture map, renewal
mills, looking at food waste.
And they mentor them and
give them the business skills
to then meet with
venture capitalists.
And they come together.
And it's been an
unbelievable success
of marrying both that
nonprofit incubator
approach of mentorship
with the venture side.
So I think you're going
to see more of those.
And I think it's very
exciting because I
know that's part of what
the next generation is very
interested in, not just
the NGO, but how can they
actually take their
dollars and put
it to work in a
philanthropic way, but also
an entrepreneurial way as well.
EMMA FALLONE: Absolutely.
Thank you.
So I know we do have
time for questions.
And there are mics
on either end.
So I'd love to invite the
audience members to start
coming up to ask questions.
But before that, I did
have just one a bit
more fun of a question to
ask as people are coming up.
I was fortunate enough to be
able to see the collection as
well before it went to auction,
and like everyone else,
was completely blown away by
all of the different pieces
and the incredible job that
Christie's did with presenting
it and really showcasing it.
So I would love to hear
from each of you-- what
was one piece that
you particularly--
not a favorite,
but maybe something
that had more meaning to you, or
something that you particularly
were drawn to.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
Gosh, there were so many.
There was a beautiful desk.
And Jonathan can describe
it in greater detail
certainly than I can.
And it sat in what was
called the morning room.
I think it was
where the light was
good in the morning in my
parents' New York brownstone.
And my mother, who was
a great letter writer,
would write letters
every morning.
And she had quite a few
letters to write people,
to thank people, to probably
solicit funds from, et cetera.
And she would go to
this beautiful desk
and write every morning.
So if I got up as early
as she did some morning,
I'd find her down there
with her cup of coffee
and her pad of
personal stationery,
and writing letters.
And that desk-- and you know
which one I mean, Jonathan--
went for more than 10 times,
I think, what was expected.
JONATHAN RENDELL: Which
was great for you.
And also, I think part of
the interest that the family
actually had for everybody, that
this was extraordinary moment
not just for the Rockefeller
family, but for everybody else,
and what Rockefeller
represented, you know,
the national parks, all of the
things that we learnt about
and tried to push out
there, all the things that
the Rockefellers have done.
It meant something
really serious
for somebody to go and spend
that much money on a desk.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Wonderful.
JONATHAN RENDELL:
She also taught
you to write very good letters.
I'd like to just
throw that out there.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
He's a great writer.
I would say for me, the
decoys were really, really
exceptional.
And we collect decoys.
But to see the way
that Christie's placed
them was just spectacular.
And it really spoke, I
thought, to that blend
of sculpture and observation.
We're birdwatchers.
So we go out, and wherever
we travel, we look at birds.
We both have a
particular interest
in sort of the
sculptural aspects
of the decoys, and the care, and
the carving, and the details.
So I just loved how
Christie's put that together,
that whole room.
And I think you said there were
a lot of people, surprisingly,
that were very
interested in the decoys.
JONATHAN RENDELL: Who
stayed up until 2:00
in the morning to
actually buy duck decoys.
Who knew that there would
be such an interested group
of new enthusiasts?
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Exactly.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: That's wonderful.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: That's great.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Yeah.
EMMA FALLONE: All right, we'll
start over here with questions
then.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Tina Daniels.
I work in the LCS Agency team.
Thank you so much
for this presentation
and also for your
service to the world.
I have a question about the
preparation and planning
that you maybe gave to the
agencies and nonprofits that
received the money.
But if I could ask
a two-part question.
The last conversation
just made me think.
I wonder, was there
any sentimentality
in this experience that
made you sad, to give up
some of these family
heirlooms or works?
And I'm presuming it was never
much of a decision to do this.
Or was it?
And do you miss some of the art?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
It's a fair question.
And I think each
member of the family
would answer it differently.
But I'll answer it my way,
which is that what I miss
is really the gestalt, the
entire feeling of being
in the three houses that
principally held the art,
not so much about
individual objects.
But as a child, you
grow up, and you
have a feeling about the
place that you grow up
in-- your own
room, or the warmth
of the kitchen in the
morning, or whatever it is.
So it's not being able to
go back to those places
that I miss.
And luckily, some of
the wonderful pieces--
not the ones that went
through the auction--
have gone to museums.
And so I have visitation
rights at MoMA, at the National
Gallery, and the Museum
of Fine Arts in Boston,
and some other places that
have wonderful pieces.
And I will visit them.
AUDIENCE: So I'm most
curious about how
you helped prepare these
nonprofits to receive
the money that they received.
And I think about my
own experience chairing
a small nonprofit in New York.
And I can imagine
we would absolutely
thrilled to receive a
substantial amount of money.
But also, some are
paralyzed by it.
And how did you work
with them to ensure
that they were prepared
to receive the money
and it would be spent
in accordance with what
you wanted.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
It's a good question.
So my father was a
very orderly person.
And both of my parents were also
very loyal to the institution.
So these weren't
sudden connections
to the 12 charities.
It was also true that my
father's will was public.
And the 12 were
named in the will.
He died in March of last year.
So between the
publication of the will
and the receipt of
dollars, each institution
knew what number was
written down for them.
So they could begin to prepare.
And you're absolutely right.
As wonderful as it is
to receive new money,
are you prepared to invest it?
Have you got an idea of how to
use the-- if it's going to be
endowment--
the income?
Does that mean you're
going to hire more people?
And it won't really probably
be until later this year
that all of the funds
will be received.
So there's a little
digestion time.
But it's a very good question.
And these institutions,
now that they're
beginning to learn that they may
be having even more than what
was in the will
coming to them, thanks
to the great success
of the auction,
they may be
scrambling a bit too.
But it's a good problem to have.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First off, Susan
and David, thank
you so much for all
the work you have done.
And I really appreciate
you taking a long-term view
in supporting the charities.
And I actually
have two questions.
So the first question
is for Jonathan.
So you has mentioned the auction
has changed how Christie's does
the work as well.
Can you elaborate on that,
like exactly what changes
has happened since the auction?
And then my second
question is, what do you
think governments
and big corporations
like Google can do more in
supporting philanthropy?
JONATHAN RENDELL: I think
for Christie's, what
was really interesting was
to talk with my colleagues
about how this was different
from every other big sale we
had done.
There have been
other sales which
have got large charitable
contributions coming from them.
In this particular case,
it was the entire thing.
And corporately, we felt
different in that there
was a real
responsibility that came
with the privilege of
having the sale, which was,
we had to make this money.
The money had already been
organized by Mr. and Mrs.
Rockefeller.
And we knew we were
going to be OK.
I mean, you know when
you get a sale like this,
you can taste it
almost immediately,
that it's going to be a success.
You know there's a buzz
that begins to build.
And it may begin with
six of us sitting
in an office talking about it.
And then the whole company
took hold of what was going on
and became proud.
And there were people
who were willing to stay
till 2:00 in the morning to
do phone bidding with clients
and feel proud
that they were part
of this great corporate effort.
The pressure was on us to
see how much more we could
raise than the required funds.
How much was what we
were doing individually
contributing to
raising yet more,
an additional, well,
almost $200 million
that will go to the charities,
that will go the philanthropy.
So that, no pressure, makes a
difference when you're giving,
in my case, the 50th
guided tour of the week,
walking people through
the collection.
You have to stay enthusiastic.
You have to stay
on top of things.
My colleagues who were producing
Instagram posts every day
and trying to make it
interesting and attractive.
And it was all about
how are we going
to make this even better than
we know it's going to be?
How are we going to, as
a company, get together?
And there's also a
great unifying thing
when a company is working
on something like this.
Everybody feels involved.
In our case, from the
maintenance staff right the way
through to the chairman's
office, I mean,
everybody in the company felt
that they had a role to play.
And we made sure that
everybody had a role to play.
And I think corporately
that made a huge difference.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: Do you want
me to start on the other
part of the question, which
I think was about government
and corporate philanthropy?
Let's just take in
the US at the moment.
The belief system of the current
administration in Washington
is so different from
previous belief systems.
What that means is
that, because we're
in the field of
environment, there's
going to be more emphasis on
corporate and philanthropic
help for environmental causes.
And so that scene
has really shifted.
And it puts a lot of
pressure on philanthropies
and corporate
philanthropy as well
to pick up part
of the burden that
used to be in the
government's pocket.
So that's a very
important switch.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER:
And I would just
say that I hear
about people getting
their interviews for
Google, and that everybody
wants to work here.
So the intelligence, the
IQ factor is top level.
And there's so much
opportunity for the employees
here to make a difference.
So we were thrilled--
Oceana was thrilled that Google
partnered with us to come up
with this innovative
surveillance system
to really make sure that we
could curb illegal fishing.
I think there's a huge amount
of opportunity for Google to get
involved using their
technological know how
and their reach.
And I would leave it up to
the ingenuity and creativity
of the people here.
And I don't know
exactly what kind
of CSR or philanthropic arms you
have a place to really mobilize
some of your employees to
do programs or get involved
in certain initiatives
or activations.
But I think just having
that conversation
and seeing where we can go.
And I know you have
Google X and you
have a lot of really
interesting funding vehicles,
especially in food,
I know in California,
because I am hearing about
that through Food Systems 6.
So I think harnessing the
technological know how
and capacity of what
you can do here,
and addressing some of these
global problems in agriculture,
with climate change,
it would be wonderful
if you could streamline
those efforts.
EMMA FALLONE: Great.
And I think we have time for one
more question, maybe two if we
make it fast.
So--
AUDIENCE: You were
first if you want to.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I just have a quick question.
My name's Matt, a
long-time New Yorker,
so I've always grown
up appreciating
everything you've done for
the community in New York.
I actually had a
question about art.
You hear and read
more and more today,
and I'm sure you guys
see it, that art is now
being touted as an
investment vehicle
more so than ever
previously before.
And I'm curious as to what
you guys think, and see,
and in the circles
that you guys run in,
in terms of, is this a positive
or a negative effect in the art
world, where folks are now
looking at art as something
that can appreciate, rather
than just the ability
to appreciate art.
And what's this going to
do to art in the long term?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR: Big one.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, there are pluses
and minuses, I would say.
I mean, for me, the most
important thing about art
is its ability to move us, to
impel us to greater heights,
to help us look into
the human condition, all
the wonderful things
that art does.
And I'm talking about not only
visual arts, but all the arts.
On the other hand, as
art in the visual field
has gotten so expensive,
it puts it out
of reach of a lot of people.
You can only have
so much in museums.
And I think it, for some
people, does make art
a commodity instead of a
great human expression.
So I think that it's wonderful
for the artists who are selling
their art at great prices
and dispiriting for those who
don't.
There's so many
things in our culture
where the split between
the highest and the lowest
is so great.
And art now has become
one of those areas,
you know, professional sports,
corporate executives, whatever.
So it's another example of that.
And that part of the equation,
Christie's benefits from.
Our auction benefited us from.
But is that piece of art
one million times better
than that piece of art just
because the price says so?
Not necessarily.
JONATHAN RENDELL: I think
individual ownership is not
necessarily the way in which
you should judge a work of art.
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: Here, here.
JONATHAN RENDELL:
That some people like
to own very expensive objects.
And there will always
be those people.
Thank god, because
that pays my bills.
But it's equally possible to
get that feeling of elevation
that a great work of
art conveys to you
by going to see it in
a museum, by looking
at a great piece
of architecture,
by listening to music.
I mean, there are so
many different ways
that are not to do with the
capitalization of the object.
So I think we live in a very--
I live in a very rarefied
world in which people spend
a lot of money on objects.
Do I identify myself
in that world?
No, not necessarily.
I am equally happy
going to a museum
and looking at an object.
And I too have visitation
rights on some of the things
I've sold in the
past at museums.
And that's a huge satisfaction
because you've put
something in the public arena.
So I think that the art market
is not necessarily related
to the true art world.
SUSAN ROCKEFELLER: Can I just
say that you can go to museums.
No, I thought that
was very good.
But also, I think it's great
just to go to galleries.
Go to the Lower East Side.
Go to Brooklyn.
Go look, and train your eye.
And if you like something, I
mean, there's a lot of art.
This is about emerging art.
And you could make
a small contribution
to someone's art career that
can totally change their lives.
And I agree with you that
some art has this crazy price
tag to it.
And then there's other artists
that are unbelievably talented.
They will never-- well, maybe.
Doubtful that many
of them will ever
get to the heights of some of
those that were auctioned off.
But that doesn't mean that they
aren't unbelievably talented,
and that you can enjoy
looking at the pieces.
So I'm one for really
looking at emerging arts.
And we support arts
whenever we travel.
We will buy something.
And it can be ceramic.
It could be a carving.
It could be something that's
been repurposed from Coca-Cola
cans, sort of upcycled art.
And then those become some
of the memories of our lives.
And if they end up
having value, great.
But we love living with them.
So--
DAVID ROCKEFELLER
JR: That's nice.
EMMA FALLONE: Then
really quickly.
AUDIENCE: My question
was answered.
EMMA FALLONE: All right, well,
that's a pretty fabulous note
to end on.
Does anyone have
any final thoughts?
DAVID ROCKEFELLER JR:
Thanks for being here.
EMMA FALLONE: Well, then,
thanks so much for being here.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]